Precedence and associativity were not so tough,
which is convenient because they're also super easy in Python.
For our parser, in Python, we can just write out a table:
a single variable, called Precedence,
that lists lower precedence operators at the top
and higher precedence operators at the bottom.
And I know what you're thinking: this is totally reversed--
and you're exactly right, but it's not the first thing we've grown
upside down in computer science programming languages.
So lower precedence operators that bind very weakly--up here at the top;
higher precedence operators that you have to do first--down here at the bottom.
And we can also indicate their associativity at the same time.
So we're going to have our precedence and associativity.
This says that Times and Divide are both left-associative
and they're very high precedence.
Plus and Minus are both left-associative and they're lower precedence.
And then our parser will automatically
get rid of the ambiguity for us by using these rules.